so we left off with uh kind of finishing
up some of the settings and uh
non-adaptive experimental design
where we
uh kind of considered at the end when we
knew the markov equivalents class would
start off
so i'll go through some
uh kind of considerations when we're
going into an adaptive setting um also
all of this is going to be with the
fixed mark hub equivalence class i think
has pointed out
a few times before
basically if
that's kind of
uh
general as long as you have access to a
um
the observational version of the system
is where you don't do an intervention
so this is kind of without loss of
generality compared to the non-adaptive
case
and i'm going to start by
discussing some options that we have for
greedy strategies
and i'll discuss at least why one of
these
which at first glance kind of seems
intuitive and like the first thing that
you would want to do can be pretty
sub-optimal and then go into a different
algorithm that
you can actually show
in a special case so this is going to be
when the essential graph is a tree
you can get within a factor of two from
the optimal intervention in terms of the
expected amount of interventions
you're going to use so that's kind of
the trajectory that we're going to take
from here
um so
i kind of divided the
types of greedy strategies we might
consider into two columns so you might
consider on the left like a worst case
uh where what you're trying to do is
um kind of greedily pick intervention so
if you take your current intervention
set as this calligraphic eye
then you're trying to pick an
intervention that you can add to that
set i didn't write kind of the
quantification over which interventions
we might be choosing from because that
would vary from algorithm to algorithm
or setting to setting
um and you're trying to
you know
get rid of um
get rid of as much uncertainty as
possible so you're trying to minimize
kind of the number of undirected edges
in this case we're going to consider the
worst case over all of the graphs in the
interventional markup equivalence class
and i have some citations for papers
that actually use this type of strategy
where this is proposed
um so
one is this house written bowman paper
and then one is the paper on k node
so bounded kind of small size
interventions
that i referenced earlier
in the fixed mec they also give the
non-adaptive case
so you can also
think about instead of kind of
choosing something for the worst case
choosing something for an average case
where again we would be using something
like a
sampler over the
[Music]
uniform distribution on the
interventional markov equivalence class
to compute
the
[Music]
quantity that we're trying to minimize
this is just kind of running through
some options that might come to mind you
might say okay well the
number of edges is
only kind of one
uh measure of the uncertainty that you
have in a graph uh but this doesn't
actually tell you how many uh members
are in the markup equivalence class so
if you're thinking from a more
information theoretic standpoint you
might be thinking about
the entropy like the total if you have a
uniform distribution over uh all of the
things in your markup
interventional markup equivalence class
this would be log of the total number of
members in that equivalence class
and here i've just neglected the log
because it's a maximization
doesn't matter
since that's monotonic but i included it
in the
expected value case um so again this is
i think about uh
all of the graphs that could be in the
markup equivalence class if that was the
true graph and i did this intervention
how much do i reduce the entropy
um and that's these two strategies are
also explored in a previous paper
um
and finally
uh you could think about
uh we saw kind of the
size of the largest clique was an
important kind of quantity
in at least the passive design case so
you could think of trying to minimize
the size of that iteratively and i'm not
aware of any papers that
kind of explore theoretical properties
of this strategy it's kind of high level
you know what our options for 3d
strategies might be you might be able to
come up with kind of other
ways of quantifying
um besides worst case or average case
and you might be able to come up with
other ways of quantifying the amount of
remaining uncertainty but this would be
kind of the style of a typical greedy
algorithm here
um
yeah so just this is just recapping the
setting we're gonna think about adaptive
we're still going to be in the
setting where we want to
completely identify the graph we have
observational data and now we're going
to have a number of interventions be
bounded and in particular
i'll kind of give the argument for a
case of single node interventions
so
trees are really easy kind of graphs to
think about in terms of markov
equivalents so if you consider
the
essential graph of a markov equivalence
class
being a tree
does anybody have a guess on like how
many possible members of this markov
equivalence class there might be
the number of notes right and the way
that you can see this is uh so for a dag
you can always identify
a source node
at least one node will have no
edges into it so if i pick a node as the
source node
um you know okay all now all the edges
are pointing out of it and then uh this
is again by the make rule that we don't
form any near v structures we kind of
propagate these edges throughout the
graph so the choice of the root node of
this tree
uniquely identifies the member of the
markov equivalence class these are in
like a one-to-one relationship so you
can think of
finding the
true dag as equivalent to the problem of
finding the root note in this tree
okay so
there's this kind of wacky construction
of a case where the
um what i call the information greedy
strategy so this is where you're trying
to
maximize the average
uh
information gain or the average or
minimize the average amount of entropy
left in your distribution
um is going to be actually using an
exponentially sub-optimal number of
interventions um in this kind of
construction
you'll see
uh we have like a three area tree so it
branches
from the root node uh
three times until at the very end
we're going to have this
giant number of nodes hanging off of the
bottom
so right now i'm just going to call that
m i'm going to call
the thing in the bottom row or the
penultimate row
the number of nodes there k
so the construction makes sense
um
now let's consider what happens
when we
intervene on any node that's not in
penultimate layer so
uh
there's
a one over p probability if we're using
a uniform distribution
over the markov equivalence class that
that's actually the root node if this
was the root node
then uh because of those meek rules
we would get all of the information
about the dag so here i'm doing this in
terms of the expected information gain
so that's where this first term the
log p over p comes from
and in the rest of the uh
cases so then the root node is going to
be
any of the other nodes um and all i'm
going to do is identify which of the
subtrees it's in so essentially if
if this node is not
the root node
i'll be able to identify everything
downstream of it
so say
i find that
all of these are downstream and this is
upstream so there will be still
one big branch
where the uh
where you can't identify anything else
so you still have at least that many of
the the variables left
and because of the the fact that all of
the nodes have degree bounded by four
um i also didn't realize
the slides were going to disappear when
i drew stuff on the board
i don't know if that's possible to avoid
okay
okay
there we go
so
basically we're going to be breaking the
set of
um
p minus one
nodes
up into
uh at most four different
sets and we're only going to be able to
identify that it's in one of those other
sets so that's going to bound the number
that's that we can get from this
intervention by two so this is roughly
going to scale that's two because that
log p over p is going to
go to zero is we take p to infinity
but if we instead think of intervening
on one of the nodes in the penultimate
layer
we
will generally get
an expectation a lot more information
and that's because if
it's actually if the root node is
actually any of the things here at the
bottom
then uh by
intervening at
this node and getting that we've
actually identified this as the root
node and then the whole graph gets
oriented and so that happens
um
if you think of k things in the last
layer
that will happen one over k of the time
so that's why we're going to get you'll
see the first term is 1 over k and then
you're getting log p bits of information
and here we can even just lower bound
that so p is always going to be greater
than m which is the number of things
just in this subtree and this shows that
the k and the m are independent so i can
take m as large as i want say i may get
two to the p squared so this would never
really happen in practice but this is
just a kind of counter example for why
the information greedy strategy won't
work
so we've established that the
penultimate layer those are the notes
that are going to be chosen
now what happens is that
even if
the
true markov equivalence class even if
the only things were possibly
uh the nodes in that penultimate layer
being the root node we would
still only get any single one of those
correct if we guessed it at random one
over k at the time
so an expectation it's going to take at
least k over two interventions for us to
pick out the true root note if you just
imagine going from left to right
um
uh but
there is an algorithm that kind of takes
advantage of the fact that this is a
tree
which can find
the
root node in
at most
uh logarithmic time in k
and this is basically you can think of
as like a bisection search so
the strategy is to intervene on a node
where
whenever we remove that node so we'll
break the tree into a bunch of separate
connected components
um then the largest of those remaining
connected components is as small as
possible so this is somehow equal to
like the minimum max entropy strategy
because we want to break it up as much
as possible
why the true structure or is that kind
of the setting right now is we're
assuming this tree structure
yes yes so this is supposing that your
essential graph is a truth okay um so
this is
uh
kind of a starting point for analyzing
the adaptive setting and kind of
thinking about the difference
so like this could have been the
essential graph
and this shows that the information
greedy strategy can be exponentially
sub-optimal for some choice of
exponential right so it's this is a
starting point to extend towards
non-treaty yes
exactly
so yeah this is just kind of here's an
existence statement of
their
the strategy
takes uh k over two interventions and
there exists a strategy that takes log
of k interventions
um so you can show this gap at least in
one setting
um whether or not this gap is kind of a
general thing
i think is an open problem you could
probably put
you know constraints on what the
essential graph is that would lead to
this not being a problem
but it'd be interesting to kind of
figure out what sort of constraints you
need for that
so
what the central node algorithm would do
is kind of if you're like staring at
this what you might enjoy
i would pick the node at the middle
um but the at the very top
uh so
say you know
most one of these can just be pointing
in
um and that reduces the amount of
possibilities uh to just the thing on
the right then i can continue doing this
so i can do this same game for like any
depth of tree
um
and in general uh
there's this nice property of trees that
they always have
um a
[Music]
what's called a central node
in this literature which is a node where
when you remove it all of the remaining
subcomponents are at most
uh
half the size of the original tree that
you started with so essentially this is
telling you at each of the interventions
that you do here you get one bit of
information because you're reducing the
size uh by half
and we already said that the number of
intervention or the number of possible
representatives in the markov
equivalence class is p
and that can be encoded in
um you know most
ceiling of log p interventions uh so
that's
in that many bits so
that's exactly how many intervention
single node interventions we need in
order to recover the tree using this
strategy that's an upper bound
and then furthermore you can show that
the
expected number of interventions that
would be required by this strategy
is going to be at most
uh twice the expected number that's
required by
the
any other algorithm
so this is showing somehow that trees
take at most
logarithmic
um
or at best logarithmic and p
interventions to orient adaptively um
and this is to kind of be compared to
um
if you knew the graph ahead of time
um and you were just kind of trying to
check it then it would only require one
intervention on the root node to verify
that that was the right
uh graph so
there's kind of a gap between these two
settings as you might expect
so that was pretty quick through
the adaptive
strategies
i could talk a little bit more about how
these
generalized to
non-trees
um
it ends up becoming pretty technical
or i could move on to some
things outside of kind of what i've
talked about so far where the goal is
just getting either the most information
about the graph
or
identifying the graph and the fewest
number of
either interventions about or
found uh tree
use cases like
i know you're talking about gene
networks makes me think
pathways
have yeah have people sort of done that
um that's my knowledge there's not been
much fun like people study like
tree-based graphical models for things
like biogenetics um
but
not as much in the kind of like genomic
like kind of uh structure discovery
any other questions
on
the style of algorithm
a lot of the papers in this space are
not providing theoretical results
they're kind of more
showing how you might do the
optimization how
these uh different choices perform um so
that's kind of more theoretically
focused talk uh i didn't put those in
here um i'm happy to discuss
maybe some of those comparisons
afterwards
um so we'll go into kind of the
the last section i might be ending uh
pretty early now so
uh
maybe before you move on
so
uh so far we talked about minimizing our
number of interventions
i was thinking like be more social
settings
if they consider other cost functions
functions uh
be probably
considered
also having a different objective
i would make the optimization of course
it depends on function but uh
with these results
standards if they have
yeah i think many of them could be um so
the only thing that i'm aware of um
is one paper in the passive setting and
some follow-up work
and what they do is
they take
a
uh
you're allowed to assign for each node
the cost of intervening on that but then
for each intervention the cost is just
the sum of intervening on all the nodes
so
interviewing on node one costs you a
dollar and you're being under two cost
of two dollars nerving on them together
it costs you three dollars you can't
kind of say oh it's actually carter
interviewing on two
things at the same time so now that's
gonna be five dollars or something like
that
so the paper i'm trying to get to
that mentions that is
it's okay i can ask you a
letter this cost optimal learning of
council graphs
so you've said that it gets a lot more
technical if you go beyond trees yeah
can you give like some ideas of what
yeah so
i brought up the fact that um
i can't even go back to the result right
around here um that the
chain components of these um
interventional essential graphs are
chordal graphs
um and
one of the characterizations of chordal
graphs is that they have
these
nice things called click treats
so you take all of the maximal clicks
i'll actually draw something on the
board here
this should be a
crash
the way that you construct the clique
tree is you find the maximal cliques um
and you make those nodes in a new tree
so here the maximum sleeks would be one
two three four and three four five
um
and in general you can show that there's
there's a way to
uh
put these together so that the resulting
graph over here is a tree and satisfies
some certain properties so that gets you
kind of from the chordal graph space to
the tree space
now the difficulty is that in the
you could imagine okay maybe i
take the same
approach of finding like a central
clique in the sleek tree
um
the difficulty is that
in the case of single nodes being each
of the actual nodes here when we did an
intervention if we got an edge like this
we were able to kind of propagate all of
those
orientations
so the problem here is that
sometimes you can propagate the
orientations
um
and sometimes you can't so in particular
if you label these
according to what's in the intersection
then you can propagate these
orientations
as long as
these two sets
say
are
incomparable so neither one is a subset
of the other
but you cannot propagate the orientation
if they are
comparable
um
so you can prove that a version of like
the click trees this central node
algorithm
works
if you're in
a setting where uh there's the click
tree doesn't have any of these kind of
comparable
labels comparable intersections between
groups
and then you have to start defining a
bunch of things to kind of handle the
case where they
they you do allow that comparability
between the subsets
so
moving on to
my last
section
um
going through all these
um
the first thing i want to discuss
is
uh this idea of targeted experimental
design so
thus far we've been kind of arbitrarily
saying our goal is to completely recover
the causal structure of the system maybe
for kind of scientific interests we
don't know how we're going to use it
downstream so we want to
completely learn it so that we can kind
of do anything that's possible that
requires that causal model but in
general
uh
you know we're actually trying to learn
something for a specific purpose so it's
rarely true that kind of all of the
structural information about the graph
is equally important so
say in the genomic setting we might care
about identifying only a
certain path like whether or not two
very one variable is a descendant of the
other or not um or you know more
complicated kind of
quantities that are kind of purely
graphical in nature or you could even
try to
so so this is considered um so this is
supposed to be the last section um which
is
where i feel like it's okay to maybe do
a few shameless plugs for some of our
work um so this is a
strategy that also uses kind of this
information greedy approach um so there
are some problems that but uh basically
takes the view of maximizing the
information gain about the target
quantity rather than about the whole
graph um and this includes the
whole graph being your target quantity
as a special case
um
[Music]
so you could either be trying to
maximize like in that we're we're
framing it as a functional of the graph
um so something that you can just look
at the causal graph and uh
tell what its value is it might also be
something that's more about kind of
like functional information about how
the causal system works
so for instance uh you might
in
biology want to find an intervention
that allows you to shift from one cell
type to a different cell type
and if you can phrase
the
beginning cell type as some
source distribution and the ins cell
type is some target distribution
you can think of finding
the the best intervention that gets you
as close as possible to the target
distribution
and that's going to be
in
another work
that our group has done
where we consider
a special case where these interventions
that we're doing
are a
form of intervention called a shift
intervention which just
adds or subtracts
to the mean of a variable
and in the gaussian case you can
uh
show how that plays out
um
so i'm going to have kind of some of the
what i see is like
interesting open questions in the field
of experimental design uh
throughout this last section
and
you know this is something you could
play around with a lot for different
learning goals about what you actually
want to figure out about your graph how
do the interventional complexity and the
sample complexity change
and at least
in the
shift intervention work
we show that there is like a x
exponential gap in the number of
interventions that might be
required to recover
just a selected piece of information
versus all the information that you want
another point is kind of this hybrid
between uh
this
uh single round experiment design and
this multi-round experiment design
um
so in the single round we said okay we
have to decide on all of our experiments
all at once and then we observe the
outcome and we don't do anything after
that and in the sequential setting we
said
i decide on one experiment i do that i
just said in the next experiment i do
that so you could have something in
between where maybe the budget that i
have to run experiments i know
here like okay i'm fine with running
four experiments
but
i'm only fine with doing that in two
batches so i could do three in the first
batch and one in the second batch vice
versa i split it equally there's a lot
of kind of options to the design choices
to make here um and kind of figuring out
what's optimal there
so
again this paper that i mentioned does
this
also in the batch setting
um kind of using these some modular
function optimization techniques that we
discussed in the passive setting for
optimization within the batches
and then information greedy kind of
approach
between batches
um
and as kind of a
pointer to a separate literature that's
considered this problem um
the kind of batched bandit problem has
been studied uh as well before so kind
of synthesizing these two lines of work
a bit more would be an interesting
direction
um and you know one of the basic
questions there is how to actually
choose to optimally
not just what interventions am i going
to do but also how do i absolutely
divide the number of interventions i'm
going to do per batch
here in the first batch you have two
different interventions
and one of them is intervening both
in blue and
green genes
but in a second that you are intervening
in red and green separately
what
why
do you think
the
importance of defining
uh
intervention
two at a time like where we do both
interventions at the same time versus
uh defining doing one and then doing the
other but doing them in the same batch
so in the same batch the red one and
green one yeah you're doing them at the
same time right right but not on the
same so so this is kind of what i was
trying to convey with this you wouldn't
be doing it on the same kind of set of
cells so you'd take one set of cells
that and apply this orange intervention
and one set of cells and apply this
green intervention separately whereas up
here
uh this
blue and green
you take one
set of cells and you
apply both the blue and the green
intervention to them both at the same
time to that same set of cells
oh so the colors are corresponding to
interventions nothing
yeah
so these are supposed to be like the
knockouts
um so
you know everybody was biting to ask
questions about
how we do things in the noisy setting
um so yeah the real world's noisy we all
know this um how much better can we do
than i think i kind of outlined a naive
strategy before of let's take
some
confidence level and
repeat interventions until we're as sure
as we want to be and then we'll just
move on
so can we do better than that
um
and there's at least two papers i know
of kind of exploring this topic um one
is
again in this causal tree setting
um
where
they consider
binary
random variables
and they use this kind of multiplicative
waste algorithm
so i don't know
a lot about this but i figured some
people do
so i would point to the fact that
they're using you know this kind of
typical methodology a lot of people use
in sequential decision making um and
applying it to that and you know showing
some
uh benefit
and then there's also
uh kind of from a different angle rather
than trying to
completely discover the causal graph
um
there's uh this paper that studies a
kind of goodness of fit testing problem
where they pause it
a
graph along with a distribution so this
is all the discrete setting
so they posit a bunch of
essentially conditional probability
distributions that where the the whole
distribution factor is according to the
graph
and then
you try to
uh probe a system
in the real world about
uh essentially whether or not uh your
kind of graphical model and equations
that you've written down are
a good uh
description of that system and the
example that they give
is
if you know in a
software you design a circuit and you
expect it to perform a certain way and
then you go and actually implement it in
hardware how do you kind of minimally
uh
choose interventions that allow you to
test whether your software model
that you expect to be implemented is
actually kind of realized in this
hardware model
um
this paper studies a few other problems
in this setting so
i think
somebody asked a question earlier about
how to
pick interventions to actually kind of
learn the equations in a model so they
also
do that where but all this is going to
be more in a kind of i have a fixed
graph that i'm being given
either i'm trying to learn the equations
for it i'm trying to test if
um
the model that i have is a good one for
the data
so i have that written here
a bit more of the formalization of that
um
so pause on this slide and if anybody
wants to ask questions about dealing
with noisy data and interventions
just a few minutes ago you mentioned uh
you gave an example of learning
learning a set of interventions to shift
like a cell from one to another yeah
that was under i think the heading of
targeted experiments with design yeah so
i'm just trying to i'm thinking about
that because i um
i'm not sure i see
the example
like in full clarity uh yeah
now you're trying to learn a set of
interventions
to do what exactly like how does the
graph
correspond to this example of like
shifting itself
yeah so
i'm not sure how that causes
where the discovery part comes in
that's a great question um
so
doing this kind of on the slide that
assumed that like the true causal graph
so so the assumption that we're making
here is that you
again will you you won't be starting
with this data but there will be
a true causal graph and the
difference
between
uh kind of your original causal graph so
you could say this is the observational
one
and
uh your target system is going to be so
imagine this is a linear structural
equation model so
each of these will
get some edge weight
and each
value will be
uh you know the edge weight times this
parent
like mean zero noise
uh so
what we're assuming is that the
the target distribution so
these
variables are going these eights
are going to induce
some observational distribution
over
uh your model
um
over the x's
um and then we assume that the
target
is
generated
by um performing shift interventions at
some set of notes
and the shift intervention is something
that says
okay i'm changing your equation so that
instead of
saying x2 is equal to like
to
x1
plus
whatever noise
you have here
it's going to be replaced
with
you still have the same dependence on
your parent but
there's this additional
bias term
the point it's going to push you up or
down by
in this case
b2 so we assume that like what's
actually going on in the real world this
is the difference between the two
distributions
and the goal is to find
the set of
nodes
along with the weights
that
get you from one to the other
and
without knowing what this causal model
is so if i just write down x 1 x 3 x 4
5 um
and so on
um
especially if i have
more edges and stuff
then you can't just look at
the beginning distribution and the end
distribution and immediately identify
what what intervention happens so you
have to know a little bit more like you
could do this if you knew the console
model you can just
look at the beginning and then
distribution and just write down where
all the shifts are happening so there's
this kind of interplay between your
uncertainty about the puzzle model and
what you're actually trying to learn
just this intervention
no again it's in the nice little setting
um
all right so
the the two things that i kind of laid
out at
the very beginning of the talk is that
we're going to focus on a noiseless
setting and then we're going to focus on
causally sufficient so what do we do if
the
system actually isn't causally
sufficient so there are some
latent confounders some things that we
don't observe that enter into the
structural equations
um
then we actually have a null result here
you can't
always identify
the true causal graph just from single
node interventions if you have these
latent confounders
um
so we can
determine this by comparing
these two graphs
so the only difference here is that
there's no edge between x1 and x3 in the
second graph everything else
is the same
but
any single node intervention that we do
if we think of
cutting out x1
so
performing a new intervention on x1
uh
then
i'll just write down all of these
smallers we have more than enough time
right so if if we
perform uh do operation on x1 we'll cut
off
this edge
uh but that doesn't give us any new
conditional independences
so we still have
um and this this will happen in in both
graphs so
even if we
were in this graph
uh where we didn't have the edge between
x1 and x3
i still see that on zoom as long as i
don't go any lower
okay
all right so
in both of these x1 and x3
are
are dependent like marginally if we
don't condition on anything they're also
dependent if we condition on x2 which is
the only other thing that we can
condition on
and then we can check all of the things
that we could possibly remove
so
if we did an intervention on
x2
what would happen
in these two graphs
so again
x1 and x3 are going to be dependent in
both of these graphs uh
there's there's no extra information
that we can get about whether that or
not that edge is there and then finally
if we
intervene on x3
both of the graphs
in both cases it's still going to be
dependent on the next one because of
this
so there's no way to tell whether or not
there's actually this edge between x1
and x3 just by using single node
interventions because of the way that
it's covered up by this l1
uh yes i
messed this up
that would be the graph after so these
are even actually the same graph there
not just
the same d separations on observed
variables
um another way would to see this would
be kind of using the mag stuff that we
used the other day and think about when
we delete uh all of these interventions
whether the resulting mags are
public
that's our null result but
there is hope
so if we
allow for interventions of
any size
at least in this graph
you can show if i delete the edge edges
into x1 and x2 i'll be able to render
things
independent so
i have x1
say
i think it was the intervention on x1
and x2 that allows you to distinguish
between these
so you just have still your edges
into x3 right
in both of these graphs
but now x3 is going to be independent of
x1 and x2 whereas in this one it still
depends on x1
all right
yes thanks
um
yeah so this is general result also in
frederick's phd
and you know one of the open questions
would be if we actually balance the
number of interventions by k
you know what are conditions on the
graph that make it identifiable of the
graph and the latent variables and so on
that make it identifiable from
interventions whose number of targets
are bounded by atmos k
um
y'all have anticipated a lot of the
kind of things that i have shown so i'm
i'm glad i was getting very good
questions
i think somebody earlier asked about
basically uh so i was giving these kind
of worst case bounds what happens
maybe i mean is one direction clear that
like if you have latent variables
k then obviously you need at least
interventions in size k i guess
is that correct chapter
uh yes the question was
if we have lane variables to point to k
nodes if we need interventions
of at least not to size k
yes right
so that was kind of in the previous
example
so we have at least two yeah
um
okay so
now we're moving on to
this question of
lower bounds that just depend on either
the graph itself or something like the
markov equivalence class
so how good can we hope to do in the
best case instead of the worst case
and this is kind of the setup that i
described earlier um just a bit more
whimsical but you know your friend comes
up and tells you that the true graph for
a causal system is this g star
um
but you you know don't completely trust
them so you want to check this out
yourself but you know if you don't want
to waste your time you're going to use a
minimal number
of interventions in this case all you
have access to is they are single node
interventions
um
so we already discussed uh in the case
of a tree you can
do this by only intervening on one node
at the root
um in the case of a clique on the other
hand
um you basically have to kind of
intervene on every other node so if they
tell you that the clique is
of the form
one two three
four five so it would have all of
these edges
basically to correctly subject
everything to an orientation test you
would have to kind of go and
intervene on every other node
so in this case it would take
two interventions so from here
you'd be able to learn
all the edges
going into four
and out of four
and from here you'd be able to learn all
that just going into two and out of two
and then you'd basically be able to
orient these other edges by make rules
so you have two to three
you can't go back
and same here two to five
you can't go back and that's going to be
the minimal number
so that you can at least guarantee that
you
uh will orient the edge between every
pair
um
and then
we have a work that shows that
you can find
a set of minimal size basically using
the same
uh property of kind of taking the
chordal graph and thinking about the
click tree and then thinking about kind
of directed versions of the clique tree
and all of those things because they're
these nice graphical operations on
chordal graphs uh are
you know linear or like low polynomial
time
um so you can get
you can
just run this algorithm
in this setting find the intervention
that that you would do
that minimizes the number of nodes that
you would want to use
however
this is not necessarily going to be
the same
number of interventions or the same set
of interventions for
every dag in a markov equivalence class
um and this is a an example
of two dags that would require different
sets and even different numbers of
interventions so you can tell these
decks have the same adjacencies and they
both have
no unshielded colliders
so they're in the same markov
equivalence class
however
for the graph on
the left
the smallest size intervention or like
two
single node interventions that you would
need to do
would be
one intervention on
this uh x
two and one intervention on this x3
versus the one on the right you can get
by with just an intervention on x2 so
it's kind of easier to see for the one
on the right you get all the edges
around
x2
and then you get the edge from x3 to x4
from basicity
for the one on the left
it's easy to see that you get all the
edges but then you have to check each of
the single node interventions and see
then all of those would leave at least
one of these edges
uh unoriented
um so in general if you want to do
something
uh that is kind of universal and like
does everything like lower bounds
everything
in the
markov equivalence class
we kind of gave a weak
thing there that's based on kind of
summing up
the sizes of the cliques or
really um
cliques minus all the cleats that kind
of come before
and the um
like tree construction that we give um
and then there's a recent paper that
gives a tighter bound and shows uh
it shows that this is like almost an
optimal balance the best better bound
you can get is like a factor of two
quick question on the previous slide the
results are for quality sufficient
systems yes
yeah yeah sorry i'm kind of bouncing
back and forth these are the only two
slides on that page yeah
oh
yeah
so
i
will give us back the final hour um
yeah i'm not
gonna go that fast to this but thank you
thank you all
[Applause]
any more questions
actually i've said another one on this
graph he said yeah
[Music]
this is this is uh
so we're only intervening on four um and
you're always able to find out the
parents and children of the thing that
you intervene on because you there's two
ways to think about it first you know
they're adjacent already so you know
this is assuming you know the more
comfortable in spots
to start off with
and then by the fact that i intervene on
this variable but these don't change
yeah that implies it's upstream and the
back of this one does change you know it
stands to scream the other way to see it
is through kind of just uh adding in
this intervention variable and then
thinking in terms of the b structures so
yeah that's how i get but yeah like a
priori kind of assumption it's
in this case like
you said we're assuming we know the
equivalence class yeah this is like a
i think this is a complete graph like
this
and that's in this example that's
particularly this example we're assuming
like we know patriarchy
yeah yeah so the setup that i was kind
of considering
um maybe
you you trust your friend to tell you
the correct markov equivalence class do
you already have enough observational
data maybe to verify the markup
equivalence class for yourself i see
yeah okay
questions
um i'm not uh sure about the literature
i'm combining kind of the the
bandit kind of i want to maximize the
outcome of a particular node
um with an unknown causal structure
you're actually working on something
like that do you have an answer to
this question um i would say like it's
not not very well
so if you knew the causal graph like
definitely um
knowing the causal graph can help you uh
determine you know which sequence of
arms that you want to pull
but if you don't know the causal graph
it's definitely a hard problem it's
pretty good
yeah
yeah so isn't that problem i think it
couldn't you know like you know maybe i
miss an important edge versus missing a
non-important edge yeah that's a really
good point um
so basically
the point is making is that uh kind of
our false negatives of whether or not an
edge is there might differ a lot based
on like how much we
how much it affects our predictions or
something based on whether or not that's
kind of a strong edge or like a very
weak edge that could almost be just
gotten rid of and give you the same
causal model um so yeah that's
definitely a problem with like these
kinds of analyses and when you do put
things in finance sample settings
usually
in order to get these results the two
papers that i cited will put
a lower bounds on kind of the strength
of the edge so
that you kind of don't run into that
but you could probably also do something
where instead of forcing everything to
be lower bounded you could just change
kind of your evaluation criterion to
take into account how strong your edges
are
yeah
i'm just wondering can you comment down
the situations with cycles
i don't know anything concentrations or
cycles um i won't actually have been
not completely sure if it's been studied
or not and
notice the papers at least
so for the last problem of uh verifying
that
was for atomic intervention
uh
it gets so um you know pointing out that
this is for single node interventions
which are also called atomic
interventions in literature um
yeah i
certainly like the proof strategy you
use doesn't extend to that um
i haven't seen people do anything with
interventions that contain more than one
node um and kind of this goes back to
some of the points about
uh having some modularity and these
other properties
break down so i think
i would take the
stuff from the results from single node
interventions a little bit with a grain
of salt because
there's potential that um you can't get
the same types of results where the
results kind of qualitatively change in
the multiple node settings
um so in a call insufficient system so
if
i uh let's say i decide the perfect
experiment that i think will work
so
but is it possible that if i
do some intervention and then i kind of
find that oh there's a major variable
that i kind of
did not think about
something
so like you have a graph that you think
it's complete
like you're not sure
about whether
so like with this type of intervention
study is it possible that they just
detect
where the latent variable is
just i believe the answer is
yes most of the the when you do the
interventions that will reveal more
information about where the variables
are but i am not the doctor
just a question from sue is there a
reference
to a real-life application using
successfully these methods
i was thinking that
one of the things that is the sacs as
all data
has been studied quite a bit in um
actually several people have have
studied it and uh i think the latest was
euros noise group
actually we analyzed it and looked at
the sequences of experiments and
stitched together the graphs from those
experiments so that's one example and
then the other that comes to mind is the
stakeholder owl paper on the flowering
patterns of uh arabidopsis kalyana
i think that also had various
interventional components within that
stage together
well a lot of these are like
retrospectives right of this dataset was
already gathered and then we look at
picking the interventions
i i haven't seen this used in kind of a
prospective setting where
you've convinced some
biologists to actually use your
intervention design strategy
and just on the cycles i was going to
say so on the cycles uh
it depends of course how you think about
what you mean by a cyclic graph but at
least let's go with the linear
model like really linear gaussian cyclic
model
for the system for which which is
perhaps the
best understood cyclic puzzle system
there there are
identifiability results of sequencing
the experiments or what combinations of
experiments you you need
to identify that
work by
anti-beauty
and jms
another question here from is there a
difference in these interventional
results between parametric advanced
parametric models especially in the
possibly sufficient settings
um i want to say yes
uh
uh for instance even the
definition of the interventional
markovic lens class
can change so
in the setting with
shift interventions
if you say
i
shift both of these values
by some
known amount and my intervention
consists of
intervening on both of these usually uh
what i would say with these two
interventions is that if you have an
intervention that
uh
i don't really know how to represent
this graphically but if you have never
mentioned it simultaneously intervenes
on both of these you wouldn't learn any
information
about x1 x2 here
you would learn information actually you
would learn the graph so you would learn
both that they are
connected because x2 would still depend
on x1 but also you'd be able to say oh
uh well i guess you would need
observational data um
so usually you from observational data
you would have this undirected and then
if you did this type of intervention
you
wouldn't gain any orientation
information but here
uh you can see that x1 actually is the
thing that's shifted by b1
but then x2 in general is not going to
be shifted by exactly b2 so there's a
way to tell these apart by incorporating
kind of additional information about
what the
uh interventions you're doing and i
think the question might be not about
the weak or strong interventions but
about whether there is a parametric
assumption about support not the console
model yeah so say linearly or something
like that versus just a completely
non-parametric setting
right
that i'm not aware of differences
yeah so
if we have if we have a confounded
system
that is linear gaussian then you know we
can even do single identifiability with
single interventions
also in like the other kind of hour i
don't have any more but i'm happy to
kind of walk through like maybe
particular questions
uh but i don't expect everybody to kind
of come back here and
watch us kind of stumble through stuff
okay
okay let's go for let's press back
[Applause]
thank you to both
to spencer daniel and
thomas as well and chanter for taking
this on to the boot camp it's an
enormous amount of work to put this sort
of day together for everyone and
they were willing to do that so
please join me in thanking all four of
them again for doing this because uh
i know it's a ton of work to do that
sort of thing so thank you all for
the outside um and then uh it's we're
not going to have the last hour in any
formal way so uh if you want to come
back and talk about i think we'll be
around um but there won't be any sort of
formation and then next week remember
it's the boot camp for the honor program
whereas uh i think brazil will be
running that show then we will we don't
have any kind of six pro six events for
the caudality program but of course uh i
think many of us will be around some of
us will perhaps attend the other
bootcamp that
will start up discussions independently
of uh uh the formal events next week and
then more more official events for the
causality program will then kick in
again
the week after that
thank you all for coming